because even i be turning down features
all day like i almost don't take no
money for features because i only do
features of people i [ __ ] with
so i'll be turning money down all day
they've been asking me to do features
since i started i've never done a paid
feature really you've never done a paid
feature one only how much did you get
paid uh it was like a favor for favor
type thing too i did someone's artist
feature so he took like five bands for
it oh yeah that's that's a deal but
they'd be offering me 15 20 30 bands
like and i don't do it why did you kind
of did you like make a conscious
decision to like not water down your
[ __ ] because you know there's rappers as
rappers
i see rappers will be doing features
with everybody talking about a thousand
two thousand dollar features like no
hell no
no yes some people that's like their
business like yo shout out to boosie
boozy will go to any city he's going to
and post it on instagram but you see boo
boo see like that but that's like his
thing yeah that's his thing
he goes to that city
it's different it's different but you
see that's why other people try to do it
like [ __ ] but you're not doing it
like him and you're not busy now he's
smart man because i think that that's
like a big mistake that a lot of young
artists make is is thinking about the
short dollar and not the long play yeah
for sure i'm thinking about the future
everything i do yeah because if your
brand is exclusive if you're not [ __ ]
with everything like
it makes it that much bigger of a deal
when you drop oh yeah but if you're like
out here holding yourself out to
everybody who's got a bag yeah stephen
thomas like it's a lot of people i do
[ __ ] with and i don't do features with
them just because i know like i don't
want to water down my brand so i'm like
yo i gotta even though you're the homie
i gotta like make sure that my brain
stay say where it's at i gotta keep my
brain on a pedestal that's smart man
that's smart